hello Internet
I do high-end today so I saw a crazy
Japanese video where people were putting
all of your shot put in rubber bands
around a watermelon and I'm quite
thirsty for watermelon right now so
we're gonna cut one open using the
classic Japanese method buzzer sounds
there you go start doing it yeah yeah
hold on this might take a while put it
take some time checking out on top it up
on the side I start to crack everywhere
just fire it oh oh bloody hell when he
seven enough
oh wow oh this incredible
the ball of rubber versus whether I
wanna find that I said it now look all
of these elastic bands were wrapped
around it and they just sort of it was
started leaking water like dripping
everywhere
and then it just gave up yeah we were
just about to put more on and then it
just let all the rubber bands was turned
into a rubber band ball and short out
leaving the melon all I saw with my own
eyes was this yeah yeah
goosh and that was just it's like proud
to cut a melon perfectly in half
look at it do you reckon if you did that
to a human head it would eventually
would cave in eventually yeah oh oh
we
Oh
oh good noise there good noise good
scoffing sound now listen listen I would
do
Oh